So once I've done the double act, then I
can set up the current node's next pointer to point
to me. And then I'll be done with joining the
cube and then I can await the predecessor to signal
me. So, I'm spinning on the got-it variable. And
how will I know that I've got the lock? Well,
my predecessor who is currently using the lock will eventually
come around And call this unlocked function. And the unlocked
function is basically taking, again, two arguments. One argument
being the name of the lock, and, and the other
argument is the guy that's making the unlock call,
in this case, the current node that's making the unlock
call. And what it does is to remove current
from. On the list and it is going to signal
the successor. And the way the successor is going to
be signalled is because the current node has an x
pointer and the x pointer says he's the next
guy waiting in line for getting this particular lock. And
he's pinning on the got it variable. So he's
just going to signal the successor. By setting the guarded variable
for the successor to be true, and that will
get me out of my spin loop, and I'll have
the lock. And I'm now running inside the critical section
having obtained the lock that's protecting the data structure associated
with that critical section. So now I'm in my
critical section. And eventually I'll get done with my
critical section. When I get done with my critical
section I have to unlock and I call the unlock
function. Normally the unlock function involves me removing myself
from this link list and then signaling the successor.
So these are the two things I have to
do. Remove myself from the list, and signal any successor.
The special case occurs. When there is no successor to
me. The special case when that occurs what I have to
do is I have to set the headnode, the dummy
node, of the link, link list, namely l to null to
indicate that there is no request... Waiting for this lock.
So that's a special case. And so if I look at
this picture here, what I have to do is I have
to set this L to null, and then I'll be done.
I don't have a successor signal. But wait, there could
be a new request that is forming. And if a new
request is forming, now this guy what you would have done
is To do a fetch and store. And, and if you
did a fetch and store on this linked list, what
would have happened is that he would've gotten my coordinates, and
you'd have set the list to point to him. So the
new request is forming, but it will not form completely yet.
In other words, the next pointer in me is
not pointing to this new request yet. And this
is the classic race condition that can occur in
parallel programs, and in this particular case, the race condition
is between the unlocker, that is me, and the
new requester that is coming to put himself on the
queue. And such race conditions are the bane of
parallel programs. And one has to be very, very watchful
for such [INAUDIBLE] conditions. And being an operating
system designer, you have to be ultra careful
to ensure that your synchronization algorithm is implemented
correctly. You don't want to give the user the experience
of the blue screen of death. You have
to think through any corner case that can happen
In this kind of scenario and design the
software in such a way, operating system in particular,
to make sure that all sets of
these conditions are completely avoided. Now, let's
return to this particular case and see how we can take care of this situation.